[Music]
our number three of the red Johnson show
up and running here in the AT&T studios
the rock the island of Staten Island is
in the house right fellow Staten
Islander from wu-tang clan back in the
day now also I've dropped the mic that
premieres tonight on TBS hosted by
Method Man here in the Rich Eisen show
what a pleasure stuff that is amazing I
bet just that knowledge didn't know that
riches from Staten Island
I am so next time you post famous Staten
Island dish in the advance which he
worked for you have to put his name in
there now we didn't notice you did not
know you did not know it's a fun fact I
gotta get that I gotta get that out
there good to see you good seat uber let
me start off by telling you Michael
Irvin sends his best to you that's my
man right there he does hey Baker I
mentioned the other day that you were
coming on he goes tell him I said hello
I love that dude so I mean you have a
certain awareness in the NFL community
you and Wu Tang Clan and your work
I think we've inspired a lot of guys to
go out there and give 110 percent
certainly I have are you fine with a
cowboy doing that
I mean being from Staten Island do you
fine with that no you know everyone
loves the cowboy so I'm just following
what everybody else in the load the
Cowboys also are you a giant or a jet
fan which one more just in Giants Long
Island kid also you know okay so yeah
Long Island to stat now and see who the
Jets and Mets met yeah so you never see
I was a jet my brother grew up a jet fan
mm-hmm so I stayed with them okay but I
realized at a very early age in my life
that I needed my championships from
somewhere that's when no ice didn't jump
that ship I Reggie Jackson started
hitting a home run okay catfish hunter
started winning games and Ron Guidry was
striking people out and I'm like that's
my team so I'm the jet Yankee slash he's
not very even though it doesn't go
together you're right it also covers
usually Giants Yankees I get it I get it
really is yeah yeah you're mixed up
right there rich come on
maybe you could straighten me out and no
one's getting me off those Yanks I mean
any every the majority of the people in
New York even myself we all bleed Yankee
blue we don't have to necessarily be
fans of the Yankees right when you think
of that NY synonymous with that blue cap
absolutely okay and so you've been that
way your whole life okay yeah but you
know I I family in the Bronx and you
know the Thurman Munson bat was really
big when I was little yeah you know
everyone wanted the Thurman Munson back
because I believe that tragedy had
happened in uh 1979 yep yep yep and uh I
remember going to a Yankee game one time
with uh something the outreach that they
used to come and get the youth and take
him to games and we were in the bleacher
seats no seats for about a corner of 50
cent apiece something like that and Dave
Winfield was out there he was a very
nice guy he waved to us and all that he
was pretty good good guy yeah my seats
either the bleachers or there was a in
the old Yankee Stadium there were
general admission where you could sit in
the last six rows of the upper deck for
like ten bucks and so I went up there we
always go right behind home plate so you
could see the entire stadium and then
and the Bronx right there over had to be
amazing it was great you know and so to
this day I'm still kind of hooked on on
all of that so you you follow the Jets
currently right now or you know what
know I've always been a Cincinnati
Bengals fan but as far as home teams go
yes it's weird it's weird because when I
when I started playing football at like
eight years old okay I remember the
Cincinnati Bengals yeah it was a few
years later they had a Cinderella season
Kenny Anderson was the quarterback Chris
Collinsworth was there I forgot what it
running back was and it's like James
Wilder or something like that I'm trying
to reserve wiki woods you know what
Nicky know not what Kenny Anderson no no
any Anderson was a gunslinger right and
um they played the 49ers and I believe
it was the 49ers yeah in the silver dome
yes they played that Super Bowl in the
silver dome
yes at Montana torch this into simple
digit numbers but I remember Montana's
horses and I just first I loved the
uniforms but then I just love this style
of play you know when I first started
watching football Cowboys were the
bottom line
like they're white cleats Billy white
shoes Johnson mm-hmm yeah just pull one
out the hand yeah pull Billy white shoes
Johnson yeah yeah he started doing the
celebrating before anybody else did so
then I would never have guessed Method
Man would have fallen in love with the
Cincinnati Bengals yeah and it's amazing
the two times that you went it was
Montana standing in the way each time
killed us killed us each time mm-hmm so
who's who's the player that you've met
in the NFL that you've just gotten the
biggest kick out of because they liked
you and your music and suddenly you're
like boy that's pretty cool for kid from
recent recent player or give me one of
each if you want well oh well back in
the day was a few guys but our RJ rising
always stuck out because we um we were
there pretty Super Bowl at a pre Super
Bowl party and he was there and he told
us out of his own mouth first play of
the game I'm gonna burn this kid for a
touchdown and sure enough when they
played the Patriots yep in a Superdome
mm-hmm yep I had to go to the Superdome
when it was still like gritty and it was
the super single you ever went to yeah
okay absolutely was and um
sure enough he he caught that pass and
burnt that kid for touch he did they
that's one of those plays I think I've
seen on NFL films that they would say
that if that if there's a certain
defense we run that plan oh that's gonna
be a touchdown yeah I know that Super
Bowl very well Chris Brockman over there
is a patriot fan plus you can see right
here I know I've got the Michigan helmet
right here Desmond Howard was the MVP of
that defensive man yeah yeah well I mean
when you think about our Michigan and
I'm not too much of a college football
guy but you know they turned out some
pretty decent defensive players Charles
Wilson absolutely first guy the first
guy name comes to well my look to me
Woodson's a goat and he's gonna get
first ballot hall-of-famer and then you
know I I've got my boys were watching
some Sunday Night Football and they're
big Patriots fans cuz it's my wife is
from the Boston area okay
you know what it is man and with the met
sister fillies yeah it's one of those
things exactly yeah it is that's an
old-school one right there
but the reason why I bring it up is when
Brady I'm like wait four kids wait to
hear him say what school he's from as
they go through the offense of the
offensive roster a Tom Brady Michigan
I'm like yeah yeah that's the goat right
there
all right so Andre Rison so Dion might
have a problem with that primer
I love prime then you know what I met
him at a UH my Tyson fight yeah we were
sitting in expensive seats
I do that because Dion was in those
seats too that's how I do daily
expensive very cool guy I follow him on
Twitter too
yeah any on Sanders yeah I definitely
okay cool let's talk about I'll drop the
mic premiering tonight yes I see you're
wearing a Late Late Show with James
Corden t-shirt yeah just on there you
know and uh you know that's my guy right
there it's my boss well this is
essentially based off of a in a way I
guess the carpool karaoke comes in a way
absolutely but you know we're not
reinventing the wheel here I mean battle
rap has been around since hip hop has
been around and um I see it as a vehicle
for those battle rappers who brought it
so much to the forefront for it to just
progress moving for more forward you
know give him another outlet or a
platform to be heard you know I mean
it's pretty cool I mean not to be taken
too seriously it's a parody basically
ensure we have celebrities come on there
who don't rhyme see that's the kick of
the show they don't run but they're
probably aspiring emcees or have done
like you know how people sing in the
shower you got people rap in the shower
now they get their chance to do that
well I mean uh sure versus Anthony
Anderson how is that even a fight though
that's just me just as a first date for
instance I believe that's on tonight yes
tonight how is that even a contest one
way to think well you know what uh sure
has a lot of rhythm is so Anthony is
very quick-witted and okay he has a he
has some rapping chops don't sleep on
him do not sleep on him and we had Halle
Berry she's gonna be on there tonight
Halle Berry who does she take on on she
takes on Corden who takes on James
mm-hmm in James's he's pretty much in
the pocket with his raps right i mean i
i'm basically a host last judge cuz i
make the final decision yes and I'm not
gonna lie to the contestants I mean I
know that they're not emcee so I'm gonna
take that with a grain of salt but if
you come up there and you stink up the
joint you're not gonna win all I know is
that if I was a judge in anything
because you referred to James Corden is
your boss technically okay if I was ever
a judge and I had to choose between my
boss and Halle Berry mm-hmm that would
be a very difficult decision to make
that's a business or actual human blood
coursing through my veins
see because you have this you have this
moral compass that holds you to a higher
standard whereas me I'm gonna stay down
here and to gut him do you like Halle
101 period ah my stuff would be packed
in the morning boss you didn't have to
say a word not a word not a word stroll
out she has this I don't know I don't
even think there's a word for it the
walk the talk she just exudes elegance
man she's our generations Diahann
Carroll yeah gratz a great pool man man
that's a great pool and I will be very
honest okay so cuz you know you live in
Los Angeles you never know who you might
run it correct so I was going I was
running jogging
trying to stay in shape okay all right
I'm so I'm jogging and then all of a
sudden have I told this story on the air
yet ever told that I didn't know you ran
what does that mean not everyone's a
jogger I'm not a jogger
I'm doing cardio okay all right so I'm
running around and then all the time and
and just not that all I'm honestly
thinking is how I'm not gonna have a
heart attack right because I'm running
around okay so I'm running around and
who is picking up I believe her kid from
a bus stop right in your pie but Halle
Berry and I'm running and I honestly
sucked in my also know that even if I
did suck in my gut Holly's not stopping
with her kid we already did it married
[Music]
and it's Haley Baldwin is also with you
Haley Baldwin is my co-host let's say
co-hosts okay cuz we're equal no matter
what people say like oh it's Michelle no
it's our show mmm myself and Haley and
she's sort of like the anchor that keeps
everybody calm and cool you know
especially with my rough around the
edges kind of demeanor she's got to
smooth things out makes the guests a
little bit more comfortable to look at a
pretty face does that mean that Alec is
gonna be dropping the mic at some point
Alec no I wish you would though
that's Trump that would be allowing
Darby Alerus actually met apoptosis even
very cool okay now let me ask you this
question before I let you go here you
were on two of my favorite shows Oz and
the wire hey I mean that is in terms of
if you had a name all time great shows
you'd have those would be on my top five
right for sure what was was that
experience like for you that's a man
being on those shows I was like my first
times ever auditioning so that was a
little stressful being on those sets we
shot ours actually in New York Chelsea
people are where Chelsea uh meat market
Meatpacking District yeah and every day
was an adventure I remember showing up
late
one time they called me it was like you
show up to work now and don't show up at
all
and I went in and I remember going back
next week and I had been murdered in the
script oh yes sir they he did not play
Tom Fontaine shout-out to you brother he
taught me about you blessed time is
everything that sounds like Belichick
right there that time is everything you
cannot play around this ain't hip-hop
it's acting and you have to be on time
not only show up but show up and the
wire what can I say David Simon has his
finger on the pulse of character just he
he personifies what the urban lifestyle
is man he just eats briefs and poops it
for lack of a better word and any time I
can get a chance to work with him I'm
jumping at all the deuce right - yeah on
HBO
yeah and James Franco Maggie Gyllenhaal
David Nina Kay Simone and George
Pelecanos I take my hat off to you guys
put it off to you guys and you put
together a piece of art that will they
can't take it away now cuz it's been
seen so now it's just there it's him
it's in history now it's in the universe
and I applaud your efforts everything
you guys have done with this show man
it's a great freaking show well you you
great in them and I'm sorry that you
were late to work on Oz but at least it
got you ready for everything else that
yes yes the day you know and for you to
be a lesson you were being cheese in the
wire she's on the walk I know and a
Juris elbow in that as well I don't want
to give anything away obviously yeah if
you haven't seen it go check out the lab
by the way you know I've got my wife and
I have Omar common t-shirts we've so you
know it's a lot of stuff that people
don't know about rich and I'm learning
this stuff as we go along
I'm impressed brother I am impressed man
I will take that real quick do you want
to ask a method man before he goes your
your question that you asked everybody
you went about a
I give you okay look now when people say
hey I'm going to visit New York City
they don't mean visit Staten Island so
do you think Staten Island is really
part of New York City you know what I
just went through this as somebody I
definitely went through this was
somebody a slitter and they were like
you know that's not even really New York
one of the five boroughs okay see it's
not a vacation destination of New York
City I want to understand I get a on
them sand but if you check for one
Staten Island is the highest point on
the eastern seaboard traversed of all
and Elkin we have the most well let's
put it this way
date night Staten Island is tops to go
but date night because we have the most
restaurants in New York City
that's right holler at your boy Kurdish
Warriors won the whole thing last year
okay 12 and Oh went to the big one
that's right won that game at Yankee
Stadium brought the title homeless New
York City yes and I want my fantasy
football yesterday really
congratulations what's the name of your
fantasy football team supreme clientele
okay yeah it's pretty is pretty supreme
clientele took it down oh by the way
that whole Staten Island chat could not
have gone any better than Method Man
check out drop the mic tonight on TBS at
10:30 p.m. Eastern Time 9:30 central
when we come back the television
auntie's will take a look at a clip with
Method Man and then the your phone calls
at 844 204 rich number down and the Kris
command center news update we'll get
some injury updates and what else do you
have over there
well we're gonna be talked about on the
news oh man controversy in the Iditarod
rich I did a lot controversy to words
that I've never put together in a
microphone let alone on this show
Method Man here on the Rich Eisen show
back with more in a moment of keeping
the cup for more Rich Eisen show tuned
to
it's channel 239 on DirecTV or download
the Rich Eisen show app